Hey
what are you doing
[Music]
demented vicious deadly in the evil
within the origins of your enemy are
unknown but their intent is not for
detective Sebastian Castellanos to
survive he'll have to withstand this
inhuman evil wait doc I think
something's coming the enemies of the
evil within are known as the haunted
tortured souls driven by one goal to
slaughter without mercy ruthless and
powerful the haunted pose a formidable
threat to Sebastian as they stalk him
relentlessly with scarce ammunition and
resources to go around even a single
enemy can send sebastian to the grave
[Music]
it's not just enemies that will tear
sebastian apart the environment itself
is laced with perilous traps tripwires
proximity explosives and noxious gas are
a few of the lethal hazards that
threaten sebastian but paying attention
to revealing clues can turn a deterrent
into a helpful weapon while the haunted
are fearsome and the surroundings are
treacherous there are some enemies so
powerful not even death can stop them
[Music]
wielding a hammer and the harvested
brains of his victims
the keeper causes evil damage with every
strike
Sebastian's survival is dependent on
keen observation and lightning quick
reactions while fleeing a dangerous
situation can be the best route to
survival that isn't always an option
by disassembling the keepers traps
Sebastian can craft votes for his most
versatile weapon the agony crossbow the
agony crossbow uses ammunition salvaged
from mechanical parts when bullets are
nowhere to be found
Sebastian can use a variety of bullets
to harpoon shock or freezes adversaries
the enemies of the evil within service
single purpose to hunt Sebastien and
kill him every encounter is a tensed
battle for survival and knowing when to
stand your ground and when to evade is
the difference between life and a
gruesome death
you